[Music]
[Applause]
peter schrager good morning football
co-host and
emmy award winner friend of the show
we were happy for you hey come on hey
everybody come on
there you go peter
congratulations to everybody at the nfl
network good morning football winning
the sports emmy last night
you know
it's it's it's cool to win and i know
that there's a lot of tweets i'm getting
like this bsdp show and i'm like you're
right
you're right
you guys are really good you know the
amount of times we played you
interviewing russell wilson that made
our show that was the content we reacted
off your show so we will gladly uh
gladly take it you know the the feelings
i have for for you guys as a family you
know it i say it all the time when we're
in person
off camera on camera or whatever i
absolutely love you guys and uh
yeah next year now i can be all on board
for you guys winning because now that we
got ours out of the way it's let's get
the right thing right here let's get you
guys yours
who did you think was going to win that
moment right before
you know what i i thought it was going
to be either us or you could tell you
why
pti has won so many times like we always
joke like beforehand kyle and i
yesterday on this show like want to just
we wanted to just congratulate uh wilbon
and kornheiser for their 600 maybe
they'll show up to the uh word ceremony
this year because i've never seen them
there but we will be there um but the
truth is those guys were on remote all
year and i'm like i don't know did they
did they have a better year this year
than any other year the sports center
won it last year i love van pelt and i
was like you guys and eisen like have a
really strong father i'm like this is
gonna be a three-horse race between us
you guys and eisen and then when they
said our name and it was like bomani
jones who a guy who i don't know that
well but like had a cool interaction
with before the ceremony he's the one
who announced it i was like this is
pretty cool and i gotta tell you i'm
very much in the self-deprecating
humility game and like you know after
what this country went through yesterday
and
and to have some moment of like pure
happiness for our crew that we do this
every day it was a really cool moment
who takes home the trophy last night
great question
uh nbc sports former employee and on-air
personality slash embassy row executive
producer michael davies
from the menin blazers i don't know if
you guys are aware that embassy road is
an outside production
company run by michael davies they do
who wants to be a millionaire and they
do jeopardy they do a few other shows
and they are the executive producers of
our show
and it airs on nfl network and michael
runs it he is
uh one of the two men in blazers he's
not raj he's the other guy and uh he's
got it in his house with about 6 000
other emmys that regis and andy cohen
and jimmy kimmel have won them in the
past
that's the guy you had a problem with at
some point didn't you
yeah he and i had a huge falling out no
that's not the guy
okay no no no no how much sleep last
night for you
none we went out after like we
celebrated and kyle
made the trip in we went out but uh it
was cool man like to see
you know obviously fifty and i were
talking and pearl and like to have the
dinettes there in the crowd it was neat
bro it was really cool it was rewarding
to see everyone from your show yeah be
nice to get that feeling of uh you know
kind of a group hug up there as we pick
up this sports emmy but that's okay i
mean i you know what why don't you
recuse yourself
for next year if you really cared about
us winning
i don't think i don't think we're
getting back to back uh sports emmy
awards
hey you know what our show was going
through it i think pat riley called it
the disease of me i think our show's
already gone through it ten times but i
think we're done
hey if i put you in charge of pro pro
bowl weekend
what would you do if or maybe michael
davies from embassy row and if he was
going to produce pro bowl weekend
what do you think that you could come up
with
i would put it after the super bowl and
i know that the nfl i might have like
shock waves going through made me
suggest it's like peter o'reilly from
the events team like don't be cute and
throw these things out there i would
move it back to hawaii i would let the
players bring eight different family
members and i wouldn't play a football
game i would just do strictly a skills
competition and i know they do one
um over there on like thursdays like and
it's a dodge ball and it's fun but like
i would love to bring back the old
quarterbacks club i would love to do a
wide receiver drill i would love to do
something um that is pure skills that
kind of have the same pizzazz as uh
as the slam dunk contest and three-point
kindness used to happen at t day but i
think you gotta shake it up and i don't
know the thought of hawaii and being out
there with your family and not having a
game the following week it sounds pretty
cool
congrats and my best to everybody on the
show well done and uh well deserving
thank you peter
love you guys thank you so much and stop
with the susan lucci stuff you guys you
guys are way better than than anything
uh deprecating like that i've been
listening and watching for over 20 years
and i love you dude thank you peter
that's peter schrager
yeah it always helps when you're a
winner when you're talking about a loser